well a blockbuster new house Republican
report has investigated President Joe
Biden
and it has found absolutely no
wrongdoing by President Joe Biden it's
really important whenever you hear they
won't even let us investigate big Pharma
won't let us investigate whether niacin
works for depression oh actually there's
a bunch of studies on that that's been
investigated oh well they won't let us
investigate what the vaccine oh the
vaccine's been investigated and they
won't let us test whether
hydroxychloroquine when snorted through
a Neti Pot treats Cove it's they've
looked at hydroxychloroquine so many
times at this point so whenever you hear
we're not even allowed well let's look
as you were hearing on Fox News and
elsewhere that they simply can't get
what they need the Whistleblower is
missing it's all being obstructed they
don't know what crimes Hunter Biden or
Joe Biden might have might have
committed you go to the New York Times
which by the way isn't failing and it's
certainly not fake and you find house
wait a second what house Republican
report
finds no evidence of wrongdoing by
President Biden after months of
Investigation months they've been
they've been looking into this yes after
months of investigation and many public
accusations of corruption against Mr
Biden and his family the first report of
the Premier house Republican this is a
republican inquiry showed no proof of
such misconduct
what and here you see Republicans on the
oversight committee standing very
strongly and announcing we didn't find
any wrongdoing they investigated four
months we'll link to this article by
Luke Broadwater it's a good summary four
months of Investigation House
Republicans promised to use their
majority to unearth evidence of
wrongdoing by Biden acknowledged that
they had yet to uncover
any incriminating material about him
despite frequent insinuations that he
and his family have been involved in
criminal conduct and Corruption
even the Republicans can't find it Well
it must be a cover-up right I mean these
soros-backed Republicans must have been
up to no good or something along those
lines at a much publicized news
conference on Capitol Hill can you
imagine the build up we're finally going
to hear about it they're holding a press
conference they're going to come with
the with the the the receipts and we're
going to find out once and for all all
of the crimes that Biden committed and
they go yeah we actually have no our
preliminary findings are no wrongdoing
whatsoever we found no incriminating
evidence at all
they released financial documents
detailing how some of the presidents
um uh relatives were paid money during a
period of time they are calling it
influence peddling but there's not
actually any evidence of that
uh and they've conceded that there is no
evidence of a specific corrupt action
that Biden has taken while in office not
a single corrupt action in connection
with any of the business deals that
Hunter Biden was involved in they said
uh I mean I don't know what else to say
they just they don't have any evidence
it also the article also explains
Federal prosecutors have examined Hunter
Biden's international business
activities as part of a criminal
investigation but the only charges
they're considering are unrelated to his
work abroad they include tax charges
related to failure to file tax returns
for several years and lying about his
drug use on a federal file a form he
filled out to purchase a handgun hey you
know what if that's what you've got
Hunter Biden on by all means go ahead
and prosecute charge them I don't see
anyone on the left running interference
for Hunter Biden to point out that
Hunter Biden has nothing to do with Joe
Biden's presidency that Joe Biden's
presidency has not exhibited any
evidence of crime or fraud of any sort
and by the way if there were such
evidence I would want to know about it I
wouldn't work to cover it up as someone
who voted for Biden over Trump if we
have evidence that a president engaged
in fraud
I don't care whether they're a democrat
or a republican I want to see the
evidence so many Republicans responding
to this report by saying clearly this is
part of the cover-up Soros got to the
oversight committee maybe it was antifa
but what they are doing is wasting more
and more and more time and resources and
taxpayer Money for Nothing it may be
time by the way to to close up Obama
gate as well you still remember when
Trump told us Obama gate was the crime
of the century the political crime of
the century and a reporter said can you
tell us what the crimes were and Trump
looked at him and with a straight face
said you know what they are you know
what they are well maybe it's time to
close the book on Obama gate as well I
don't know where we're going on that but
certainly don't seem to be making any
progress whatsoever